what is bitcoin
bitcoin is a software and it's a
distributed software to operate a
peer-to-peer network between
members who are all equal on the network
they're all peers
and what this software does is that it
allows you to operate a
payment network
between those peers and the payment
network has its own currency
and that seems like you know just a
simple software game but the reason this
is such a big deal is i believe bitcoin
is the most advanced form of money ever
invented
and the reason for that comes from two
properties that this network has
the first one
is that the currency is the hardest
money ever invented it's the money whose
supply
is the most resistant to inflation it's
the first monetary asset that we've ever
invented that is guaranteed to be fixed
in its supply that cannot be increased
beyond a certain number so there's only
ever going to be 21 million bitcoins and
that's
that's a that's a qualitative leap
forward in our technologies of money all
of our monies
leak essentially because people can
always make more and more and more of
them you know the best money is the one
that leaks the least which is gold
because it only leaks one and a half
percent in other words your share of the
gold stock
is diluted by one and a half percent
every year ideally you'd like it to be
zero bitcoin is currently at around one
point eight percent headed towards zero
so it's the first money that we've ever
had that goes to zero in terms of
terminal supply so there'll never be
more than 21 million bitcoin i think
that's a huge deal because you know
as i said earlier
money is always whatever is the hardest
to make and now bitcoin is the hardest
thing to make
and then the second property which is
extremely important as well
is the fact that it operates
without the need to trust in anybody it
doesn't have a party that is in charge
of it it doesn't have a central
authority that can um
you know it's as i said it's
peer-to-peer so there's it only has
users it doesn't have any admins
there's no authority in charge of
bitcoin that can take your bitcoin that
can stop you from using bitcoin uh that
can change the rules of bitcoin they
can't make more of it so it's fixed it's
available for anybody in the world it's
the hardest money ever invented
and it is absolutely uh i think
an an enormously enormously significant
invention because
um if you read the fiat standard and the
bitcoin standard as well
you'll see my perspective for why i
think
a very large number of problems on the
world our co in the world are caused by
easy money are caused by inflation
and um caused by government having
access to essentially an infinite uh
recourse to people's wealth and i think
uh bitcoin fixes this because it allows
us to have money
that has the sustainability of gold
across time meaning it holds its value
across time
like gold but much better than gold but
also it has similar to it is similar to
fiat and that fiat can travel quickly
but bitcoin can travel even faster than
fiat so
it combines
gold's saleability across time with fiat
sealability across space
in one immutable package that nobody can
change and nobody can control can you
define the word sellability saleability
is the essential property of money it's
the ability of
a good to be sold easily on the market
specifically to be sold without much
loss in its value so houses are great
for living in but they're not very
saleable if you want to sell a house
you can just click a button and sell a
house and have a giant market of people
buying houses from you you need to find
um you need to find somebody who wants
the exact house that you have with the
exact specifications that you have and
because you know houses are not
identical there's no liquid giant market
for people to just buy and sell
identical houses from
um so uh gold for instance has uh good
saleability as money
because it's a liquid good it's uniform
and people are always buying it
fiat dollars have great sellability
because everybody's always buying and
exchanging dollars for other goods
so if you have a hundred dollar bill
you can easily get rid of it and you'll
get a hundred dollars worth of stuff for
it if you have a hundred dollars worth
of stuff it's harder to get rid of it if
you have a hundred dollar worth of phone
it's not as easy to spend it as a
hundred dollar bill that's scalability
what do you mean that bitcoin i
understand that bitcoin has the
sellability of gold across time
better even yeah better yes like on the
order whatever um and then and then has
the syllabity of fiat across space what
does that mean so if you remember when
you asked me what is the advantage of
fiat what is the um advantage offers us
it's it's cheaper to move fiat across
space than it is to move gold you know
with with the current fiat monetary
system for all of its flaws you know you
can send money uh you know i could send
money from my bank account in the us to
a bank account in
china
in a couple of days or in britain in
france in a day or two which is you know
much faster than you could do with gold
and much cheaper than you could do with
gold
but
in reality with fiat you know the reason
bitcoin improves on that is that with
bitcoin you're actually selling you're
sending final settlement in a couple of
hours
so you send the bitcoin transaction you
get six confirmations in an hour you get
about 12 confirmations in two hours on
average with 12 confirmations you know
you're pretty um definitely clearly safe
on this
so
within a couple of hours you could send
a billion dollars across the ocean
and
have final settlement on them it's not
just that you've sent a credit
obligation that's going to need weeks
and months to settle which is the case
with fiat
so it is
faster than fiat effectively so it's
harder than gold and faster than fiat
that's a good way of putting it
you